millions of Americans traveling over the
long holiday weekend in Las Vegas as
usual will be one of their top
destinations but there is one place in
town
s that yet it remains incredibly busy
day and night the county jail 8 news now
Chief investigator George Knapp ventured
Behind Bars to learn the Art and Science
of running the Clark County Detention
Center
you know most people in Booking didn't
wake up that morning so you know I think
by midnight I want to be in Chains at
the Clark County Detention Center for
something you know crazy after and
they're angry at somebody every day on
average 158 people are booked into the
Clark County Detention Center more than
57 thousand total last year and they
remain in jail for an average of 18 days
more than 400 of the inmates here are
awaiting trial for murder more than 30
of those have been waiting five years or
longer in decades past the old County
Jail was so overcrowded that Federal
authorities put it under a consent
decree its replacement facility is
carefully managed to keep a vacancy rate
of about 30 percent you know you can't
fill the jail and have that solve your
problems it just creates a whole other
set of problems so as we've learned
these things as a profession uh you know
we've been in front of that change curve
so to speak on how to make this
community safer without populating the
jail and filling the jail with people
new arrivals go through a detailed
booking process fingerprints get taken
photos are snapped of tattoos often
valuable to gang enforcement all felony
suspects must provide DNA samples an
incredibly important tool that helps
solve dozens of other serious crimes
last year male and female inmates are
segregated of course but they get
divvied up into many other subcategory
so everyone gets classified based on
their criminal history their charges
their gang affiliation we have a
classification section that's ran by our
officers where they try to house
similarly classified inmates all
together so that way you don't get
someone who's in on his first offense
for domestic violence with a roommate
who is a convicted murderer who's now
murdered again sex offenders get housed
in a separate section so do transgender
inmates in part for their own protection
military veterans as a group have common
needs and problems so they too have
their own section
getting meals and medical attention to a
constantly shifting population is an
immense challenge many who end up behind
bars are homeless and Captain Clark
estimates 40 percent of the inmates have
mental health issues requiring
medication making the jail Nevada's
largest mental health facility there's a
doctor here there's a psychologist here
there's people here that can give them
the medication that they need the
challenge is is when it's time for them
to leave
they're back out in your neighborhood
mine and the idea that they're just
going to be able to continue their care
once they leave the facility is a
fantasy the jail is not meant to be a
place to punish suspects since most here
have not been tried let alone convicted
Metro understands that it is sort of a
temporary Dumping Ground for social ills
including homelessness and mental health
the time they spend in jail presents an
opportunity for the police that can
reduce the crime rate
multiple programs have been implemented
at the jail to teach basic life skills
for when the inmates are released we are
Corrections Officers
our job is to correct the behavior the
the programs that we've brought in the
hope for prisoners DSD cares events
where we bring people in from all over
the community to help people get a
driver's license when they're released
get their social security card when
they're released to get back on
insurance when they're released all
these programs are helping these people
go back out into society and not come
back astonishingly some inmates are what
you might call frequent flyers some of
them have been arrested more than 600
times over the years most of those for
vice or prostitution overall it is a
Kinder gentler approach than the old
lock Em Up throw away the key but
Corrections Officers and staff know the
Jail's most important function Remains
the Same as ever to protect the public
by keeping the worst of the worst where
they belong unfortunately we still have
people that the only thing they know is
jail George Knapp 8 News Now